voters are angry did you know we have an
election coming up next week that's
right midterm elections that's where
pretty much nobody votes and usually the
the incumbent president his party gets
banged up and that's what it looks like
is gonna happen right now so CNN and 0
RC had a new poll out on some numbers
and let's take a look fifty-three
percent of americans disapprove of
obama's job performance that actually
doesn't strike me is that high because
considering how much [ __ ] he's getting
right now and how much uh you know stuff
is going on between Isis and Ebola and
everything else that actually seems
right thirty percent are very angry
thirty-eight percent are somewhat angry
it's a fine line between those two
thirty one percent expressed no anger
those are the people that are on
prescription drugs and forty-two percent
agree with Obama on issues that matter
most to them while fifty-five percent
say they disagree alright so as I said
these numbers actually don't seem that
polarizing to me considering how
polarizing everything seems in our
political discourse these days um and
yes the the incumbents party usually
gets crushed if you look at drudge every
day it sounds like the Republicans are
gonna storm in and crush everybody um do
you want to make any any predictions a
week before the midterms you got
anything you read this stuff all day I
see what you're doing out there Thursday
it's it's always hard to predict in this
were the world's changing again we talk
about polls early happy will express
what they think is gonna look a certain
way and what they'll say but no one
knows what they do when they get into
the ballot box and also with this I
think younger voters when and if they do
come out they're not gonna tell you what
they're gonna say before they're gonna
whatever anger they have expressed
towards Obama will be left right we're
gonna sue or conservative these fifty
three percent hate them because they
want more conservative the values and
then the rest that actually the thirty
percent that say they love everything
about a must be such lives I think a
larger size of his distrust and the
dislike for Obama comes from the left
that is upset that he didn't go that
they learn enough example that alot of
not gonna write that down in that [ __ ]
up the country's guess because he's
totally not conservative not because
he's a Democrat right is it's it's too
black and white yet you know that's
actually a great point because everyone
obviously talks about conservatives not
liking Obama but it's the it's the
liberals that are actually really angry
at him for legitimate read
is for not doing what he said he was
going to do the Conservatives didn't
want to do what he did what he said he
was gonna do need to do it I think that
made sense I think there was some sense
in there but people don't vote right
Hank I mean Pete do you vote do you go
please tell me well I you vote okay good
I repeat every time but I vote when I
can my vote counts you vote every couple
years ago whenever the view tells me to
go about all right I don't do that maybe
I do every four years old I don't care
that they always say this is the most
election important 11 I say every time
this is the most important one another
um you know in la here our mayor Eric
Garcetti I think he got thirteen percent
of the vote and he became our mayor
because nobody votes that means thirteen
percent of the constituents voted for
the guy who's in charge of our city and
then we wonder why there's potholes
blowing up all early tonight a flood in
front of my house and the power went out
again last week I mean really like the
city's crumbling but we but nobody votes
what can we do to get people to vote
more I'm engage in social media in and
give away free stuff like I like like
all the time like all the talk shows do
I mean I mean I think that's why as I
have talked about that I joking but
they've talked about it paying people or
giving what something where what was
that is and I know this which I think
most more people voted for one of the
seasons of American Idol the final as
than they did for their own president
and also it's not forget that Obama was
able to really activate a young fan base
via social media as a fact that he was
an amazing candidate and to speak on to
your point about everyone being so upset
at him I mean I whenever I see Apple
like this first you know I make up
numbers all the [ __ ] time and I like I
don't trust the I wanna know what your
sample size was usually with the CNN
holds like 2,000 people randomly serving
over the phone right like you actually
dig into the numbers are like is this
really cross section America well that's
why I try I try to deep into the numbers
apologist for the broader discussion is
everyone is gonna come at it from their
own life experience so you know for me
when I was younger taxes were not an
issue I don't care right and Obama I'm
happy with him you know why because he
was the first sitting president endorse
gay rights I'm like that's cool that's
all without subs those on my agenda I
don't a business I don't I don't you
know I don't run [ __ ] you know I don't
got
yeah that was important to you I he he
followed through on his promise to me so
I'm happy with that I can understand
someone else who's like you know who
owns of who owns bunch of people well
who oversees a bunch of people not yet
local oversees a bunch of people and now
he bombed care has screwed this whole
business model that fits me on that
would write liberal or not yeah do you
think part of the apathy is just the way
the game is played so for example with
immigration now Obama has already said
well first of the Republicans will play
ball on immigration so he can't get
anything past the way it's supposed to
be passed right where they Congress
writes a law and he signs it that's
what's supposed to work we know that's
not gonna happen so now he's trying to
do this executive action stuff but he's
already said he's not going to do
anything till after the election because
he doesn't want to hurt Democrats by
doing something politically on public
which then just shows how screwed up the
whole system is Republicans won't play
ball he is gonna have to do something
that there's even constitutional
questions and he knows will be
politically unpopular she has to wait to
act like the whole game is so [ __ ] it
soon as you get elected your next job is
to get elected again your job is not to
represent me one not to pass the laws it
the second time oh yeah but not now he
has to have the pressure being worried
about oh are you screwing up the midterm
election or his legacy yeah what is that
like like we have done and it's been on
headlines like oh can i if I'm trying to
get elected in Alaska Obama screwed up
because I'm a Democrat they're gonna say
he's just like Obama so they connected
and look at these numbers and in it
makes it in by the way I think people
are uneducated on what the system is and
how it works especially politicians are
perpetuating it coming on TV or just
speaking from whatever post they have to
say hey you know the president doing
this president is taking the country's
being a dictator do not it's impossible
for me do it but then when they want him
to be this dictator you know he's not
going over killing us with his bare
hands okay which one is it this is is
their checks about the system records it
just him running the country yeah yes
and as I say yeah I did just every week
I've been trying to say this we have
something called separation of powers in
this country so Congress is supposed to
write laws the president is supposed to
sign them into law and then the judicial
branch the court are supposed to decide
whether they're legal if we could just
apply those basic principles I think
things would be a lot better but bigger
that just boat just go out vote and
voting should be a national holiday that
would be my last one yeah that would be
my solution to this hotel